Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khoa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube và Excel bài số 1
làm quen với excel đầu tiên sẽ là khởi
động Excel nhá các bạn chú ý để khởi
động Excel thì các bạn sẽ tích vào cái
nút start ở đây này Đấy sau đó các bạn
gọi xem thì ở trên cùng nó sẽ hiện cái
ứng dụng excel nhé các bạn sẽ thích vào
đây đấy thì một cái cửa sổ Excel đã được
mở ra các bạn chú ý nhá Cái mặt định ở
đây là cái thẻ hôm ở đây là có cái thành
phần blank book tức là các bạn mở một
cái váy xòe trắng chưa có gì đúng ạ bên
này đã các cái Toto tức là các cái hướng
dẫn cơ bản của Excel nhé để có thể tích
vào đây để các bạn xem nhé Ở dưới này là
cái file Excel gần nhất mà các bạn đã sử
dụng trước đó nhá Ngoài ra thì ở đây là
cái phần lưu để các bạn thể tạo một cái
file mới ở đây là Open để các bạn có thể
mở file Excel và gọn muốn mở lại thì
trong cái loạt bài Excel cơ bản đến nước
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thích chọn cho mình là
cái blank Facebook đi Đấy sau khi các
bạn tích vào em like Facebook thì đợi nó
sẽ mở một cái file Excel trắng cho các
bạn nhá thì mặc định của Excel ở đây nó
sẽ là mốc 1 Để Nếu như các bạn mở Excel
nhiều lần thì nó sẽ là bốc hoa lúc 3 Đây
là cái tên mặc định á thì đầu tiên các
bạn cần đặt tên file cho nó nhá giống
như khi các bạn sinh một em bé thì có
phải đặt tên cho nó đúng không ạ lại
thịt để đặt tên file các bạn sẽ thích
vào cái chữ file này các bạn sẽ chọn xếp
ở đây sau đó các bạn sẽ chọn cái nơi mà
các bạn chứa cái phải xem này hoặc các
bạn có thể tích và cái browse để ví dụ
mình như ra destop đi đấy các bạn thích
trên desktop và mình sẽ chọn cái gì
Excel cơ bản đến nâng cao đấy thì tốt
nhất tất cả các file tải về Mình sẽ lưu
vào cái folder là Excel cơ bản đến nâng
cao ở cái destop đi đấy ví dụ mình đang
làm ở cái bài số 1 Đúng không các bạn sẽ
thích và 7 bài 1 ở đây qua lưu vào đây
đây ví dụ mình đặt tên nhá thì trong cái
phần file với là cái phần để các bạn đặt
tên đúng không Ví dụ mình đặt tên là bài
số 1 đấy là còn khách ra là làm quen làm
quen với excel Đây Rồi sau đó còn muốn
xếp thì các chú ý nhá ở đây sau khi các
bạn đặt tên thì nó sẽ là cái tên bài số
1 làm quen với file Excel để còn chú ý
nha Cái vùng rộng nhất trên màn hình mà
các bạn nhìn thấy ở đây này chính là các
ô của Excel thì các bạn có thể tích vào
bất kỳ video nào
ô hay còn gọi là các Cell nhá thì mỗi
một xe ở đây thì nó sẽ được tạo thành
bởi diện bởi một cái mát trận cột và ma
trận hàng ở đây thì các cái cột trong
file Excel nó sẽ được đánh số theo chữ
cái từ A này BC đấy còn các cái hành thì
nó sẽ được đánh số từ 1 đến 2 đến 3 lại
cứ như vậy nhá trong Excel từ 2007 trở
đi thì nó đã có hơn một triệu hàng và
hơn 16.000 Cột rồi cho nên cái ở đây rất
là lớn các bạn có thể nhập thoải mái nhá
ví dụ các bạn tích vào một ô bất kỳ ở
đây ví dụ như các bạn thích và luôn này
nhá thì các bạn sẽ thấy ô này nó sẽ ở
cái cột b và ở hàng số 2 đúng không ạ
Các bạn sẽ thấy cái cột b này nó hơi bôi
đậm lên một tí và cái hành số 2 này nó
cũng hơi vui động lên một tí và các bạn
sẽ nhìn ở đây Cái này con trỏ vào đây
này nó gọi là lên móc tức là tên của cái
ô mà các bạn thích vào đấy ví dụ Các bạn
thích vào đây nhá thì nó ở cái cột thép
và hàng số 2 thì trong cái phần nhưng
bác vào đây này nó sẽ hiện ở F2 đ
nó khá là hay ạ Các bạn thích và mỗi bất
kỳ ở đây thì trong kinh niên Móc nó sẽ
thể hiện cái ô đấy địa chỉ là gì đây là
cột e và hàng số 7 đấy tiếp theo mình sẽ
giới thiệu với các bạn về các cái kiểu
dữ liệu trong Excel nhá Thì với mỗi một
oxcel này thì nó sẽ chứa các các kiểu dữ
liệu khác nhau thì thông thường sẽ có
bốn cái kiểu dữ liệu đầu tiên là cái
kiểu dữ liệu chuỗi hay còn gọi là kiểu
Tech lại thì ví dụ các bạn ghi ở đây là
dịp họ tên chẳng hạn thế nhá đây sau khi
các bạn Nhập xong nhá thì có thể bấm
enter để các bạn kết thúc công việc nhập
này đấy thì nó sẽ mặc định nó sẽ xuống
dưới này hoặc là gì ạ Ví dụ ở đây là
ngày sinh thì nếu như mà sau khi bạn
Nhập xong nhá thì ngoài cái cách mà các
bạn bấm enter thì các bạn có thể tích
chuột vào cái ô bên cạnh hoặc các bạn
thích chuột ra ngoài Ví dụ mình thích
tuột vào Cái ô này thì coi như là lúc
nãy mình đã nhập xong hết một ngày sinh
đúng ạ Đấy ví dụ ở đây mình đi là gì ạ
Ví dụ ở đây là điểm Excel nhé Thì mình
sẽ ghi là Excel bên này sẽ là nhẹ vuốt
này à
Ở đây các bạn enter bên này sẽ là gì ạ
ví dụ là PowerPoint đi để gọi enter tiếp
theo là mẹ mình Ví dụ mình nhập họ tên
của một bạn đấy ví dụ ở đây là gì ạ
Nguyễn Văn A đi Nguyễn Văn A nhá rồi còn
enter sau đó bạn Di chuột lên giữa cột C
và cột b đây này các bạn sẽ thích giữa
cái cột C của bên này nó hiện cái mũi
tên kẽm gai viên thì còn tích tụ vào đây
Đấy thì nó sẽ mở rộng các cột C là do
các bạn nhá Đấy và các bạn giữ được trái
còn kéo này Đấy nó cũng mở rộng cột C
các bạn giữ được trái hoặc kéo nhá Để
lâu mở rộng cái họ tên ở đây ra cho gọn
dễ nhìn thôi nhá tiếp theo là gì Các bạn
có thể nhập cái kiểu dữ liệu là ngày
tháng thì trong các trường hợp ngày sinh
ở đây là ngày tháng đúng không ạ thì
thông thường trong Excel các bạn sẽ nhập
tháng trước và đến ngày xông lên đến năm
đấy là cánh thông thường là mặc định
thôi nhá lấy ví dụ là gì ạ ví dụ là
tháng 9 này ngày bao nhiêu Ví dụ như là
ngày 25 năm bao nhiêu bạn năm 2020 hạn
thứ nhất tao enter đấy thì đây là cái
ngày sinh tương tự thì các bạn ạ
ở cột b và bột e các bạn giữ chuột trái
và kéo rộng gây ô ô các bạn kéo rộng các
cột đây này ra đấy Tiếp theo là cái kiểu
số liệu thì có thể là kiểu số nhé ví dụ
như điểm Excel là 8 điểm đi đấy các bạn
ấn Mũi Tên Xanh đây cũng được coi như là
các bạn Nhập xong nhé điểm vuốt là
gìđiểm vuốt ví dụ là 9 điểm thấy cô ấy
mũi tên sang phải là ví dụ điểm
PowerPoint là 10 điểm đi đấy các bạn
enter như vậy Ở đây mình có một số
trường là Diệp đây trường Tết này chiều
ngày tháng trường số đấy ví dụ một chấm
công thức nhá ở đây mình sẽ nhập vào
diện đây là tổng điểm đi đấy công thức
thì bạn có thể bằng xong này sau đó gọn
Model ba cái ô này có giữ chuột trái và
các bạn kéo sang nhá từ bof4 đến OVA 4
này đấy các bạn em tư đấy nó sẽ ra tổng
điểm 27 Đây là cái dữ liệu kiểu công
thức nhá các bạn đừng quá lo lắng về các
công thức này nha mình sẽ giải thích
trong các bài học ở phía sau nhá thì đây
là mình muốn giải thích cho các bạn
các kiểu dữ liệu thôi Chỉ như vậy toàn
thủy cho mình nhé Có 4 kiểu dữ liệu phổ
biến nhất trong Excel là việc đầu tiên
là kiểu chuỗi đây chính là kiểu chữ i ở
đây thứ hai là kiểu ngày tháng thì con
Thúy Nga mặc định nó sẽ thường là nó sẽ
để tháng trước sau đến ngày thôi đến năm
thì các bạn phải nhập tháng ngày đến 5
nhá tiếp theo là tiểu dữ liệu số nhá đã
gọi Nhật số vào đây và cách kiểu dữ liệu
Tiếp theo là cái kiểu dữ liệu công thức
này các bạn sẽ tổng điểm ở đây là cái
kiểu công thức đúng không Bạn cái môn
này tám cộng 9 + 10 thì nó sẽ ra là 27
Đúng đây là cái kiểu công thức Các bạn
nhìn xuống dưới này các bạn sẽ thấy ở
đây là ship một đấy thì các bạn tưởng
tượng nhé cái file này nó giống như một
quyển sách này quyển sách nó sẽ có nhiều
Trang đúng không Thì cái ship một ở đây
coi như là một trang và Nếu như các bạn
muốn thêm một cái sim mới để thêm cái
trang thứ 2 thì qua sự tích mà cái dấu
cộng ở đây để các bạn sẽ phạm của các sĩ
mới này đấy thì nó sẽ mặc định cái sim
mới xem nào ship hay đấy Nếu các bạn
muốn thêm một ít thì có bạn lại thích
cộng vào đây thì các bạn sẽ có 3 xít đấy
thì các bạn muốn bao nhiêu xít thì gọi
xem tích dấu cộng với Đây nhá Đấy bây
giờ để sang ship một định thì bạn Di
chuột đến vsip1 này các bạn Kích chuột
trái vào đây nhá Đấy thì nó sẽ chuyển về
cái xích một để đổi tên cho cái sim này
thì các bạn sẽ thích đút cho trái đây
này để còn tiếng luôn vào đây để các bạn
đổi tên Ví dụ ở đây là gì đây là ví dụ
mình đi vào phòng tài chính đi nhé Nó
gọi enter để kết thúc cái việc đổi tên
sheet thì con sẽ đánh ghen tơi nhá ngoài
ra Ví dụ cái ship hay này các bạn muốn
đổi tên nha con có thể nháy chuột phải
này các bạn sẽ chọn cái Dinh đêm ở đây
để qua đổi tên này đại Ví dụ mình đổi
tên ở đây là gì Đây là phòng tổ chức lao
động đấy Cái sheet 3 này các bạn tích
lũy vào đây ví dụ mình biết là dự phòng
thiết kế toán đi nhá Đấy để kết thúc em
việc đổi tiêu chí này các bạn sẽ bấm
enter để như vậy đây mình có 3 phòng
không ạ Đây là cái cách cách thông
thường để mình sẽ tạo cái sheet khác
nhau đúng không ạ Ok mình sẽ hướng dẫn
các bạn một cái mẹo để mình tạm một cái
ship đấy thì mình làm như thế nào chào
các bạn sẽ giữ control lại còn giữ được
trái và cái phòng tài chính này để bạn
xếp kéo cái con chuột sang đây Các bạn
chú ý là các bạn phải giữ thật trái và
còn giữ phím cần cho bạn kéo sang đây
nhá sau đó có bỏ cái chuột trái ra đấy
và các bạn bỏ phím tiền chuyên gia Tức
là nó sẽ copy cái ship của phòng tài
chính sang đây đấy thì nó sẽ thêm các
tiền tố là viết số 2 này để phân biệt
hai cái sheet khác nhau đúng không Bây
giờ các bạn sẽ tích lũy ở đây để qua đổi
tên là đấy ví dụ ở đây là gì Đây là
phòng nhưng ở phòng kế hoạch đi nhá Đây
thì ok lúc này các bạn sẽ nhập thông tin
của các phòng kế hoạch của đây Bây giờ
mình sẽ quay lại xích đầu tiên là cái
phòng tài chính đúng ạ Đấy Cách thứ 2 để
mình tạo một cái xít mới là diệt các bạn
có thể nhấn chuột phải vào đây
anh ngu appear đấy thì nó sẽ có hai cái
tùy chọn nha Cái tube ở đây này nếu như
mà các bạn tại một cái xít mới nó vẫn
nằm trong file này thì các bạn cứ tích
vào file này còn nếu như các bạn tích
vào cái như Facebook thì nó sẽ tạo một
cái file Excel mới nhá thì ở đây mình sẽ
vẫn thích và bài số 1 ở đây đi đấy các
bạn sẽ ngu tụi em thì các bạn nghĩa là
các bạn sẽ tạo một cái sim mới xuống
cuối cùng của Đây đây nếu như các bạn
thích created copy thì nó sẽ tạo một cái
sim mới vào nó giữ nguyên cái ship phòng
tài chính ở đây nếu các bạn không thích
mà cái clip copy thì nó sẽ di chuyển cái
này xuống cuối Ví dụ mình di chuyển thức
cuối này các bạn sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy
Cái phòng tài chính sẽ di chuyển giúp
cuối đúng không Bây giờ mình muốn cái
phòng tài chính này lên cái sĩ đầu tiên
của các bạn sẽ gì ở các bạn sẽ giữ chuột
trái vào cái xếp phòng tài chính và các
bạn Duy lên đầu tiên này để sau đó còn
bỏ chữa cháy ra đấy thì như vậy Cái
phòng tài chính này nó sẽ lên đầu tiên
vậy Giả sử mình muốn cái phòng kế hoạch
nằm sau cái phòng tài chính á thì các
bạn giữ chuột trái vào cái xếp kế hoạch
A Di nó sẽ vào giữa cái phòng tài chính
và phòng tổ chức lao động đấy nó sẽ có
cái mũi tên Nhỏ đây này và các bạn bỏ từ
trái ra thì như vậy Cái phòng kế hoạch
sẽ di chuyển ở giữa phòng tài chính và
phòng tổ chức lao động nhá lấy đoạn
đường rất là hay ok để xóa sheet Chẳng
hạn bây giờ mình muốn xóa cái ship phòng
tổ chức lao động này có chi nhánh phải
một đây các bạn sẽ bấm Delete đấy để
mình xóa ship đi đấy ngoài ra cái cách
mà để tạo một cái suýt nữa thì bạn có
thể nhớ được Phải mà một sim bất kỳ Các
bạn chọn Insert đấy và các bạn sẽ chọn
cái bô xít ở đây các bạn sẽ bấm ok đấy
cũng là một cách để các bạn sẽ thêm cái
cuốc xít nhé nhưng thông thường mình ít
dùng cách đấy mình có thể dùng cách tích
bỏ dấu cộng đây nó sẽ nhanh hơn bây giờ
giả sử mình muốn xóa cái ship5 vào cái
xếp phòng kế toán nhá thì các bạn gì À
còn sẽ tích và sinh năm này sau đó còn
giữ cần chôn các bạn tích thêm vào cái
phòng kế hoạch đấy thì như vậy hai cái
sim này đã được Boram rồi đúng không còn
nhớ được phải các bạn biết đi đấy như
vậy là nó xóa hai cái sim rồi nhá Đấy là
cái cách mà có xóa nhiều sheet bằng cách
các bạn giữa
các bạn lựa chọn các sheet Ở đây các bạn
có thể tô màu cho cái tên xít ở đây ví
dụ về phòng kế hoạch các bạn nhất định
phải đây các bạn và phát KL Ví dụ mình
cho nó màu đỏ đi để còn cái phòng Tài
chính các bạn nhớ vi phạm pháp cơ thể
bạn có thể chọn Nó màu xanh thì tùy các
bạn nhé Đấy Ok như vậy là mình đã giới
thiệu qua cho bạn về các xít này rồi thì
tại sao lại cần nhiều sheet thông thường
mình cần nhiều sheet là gì Ví dụ mình có
quản lý các cái phòng hoặc quản lý các
nhân viên thì ví dụ mỗi một sheet là một
phòng hoặc mỗi một ít là một nhân viên
hay mỗi một ít là một cái kế hoạch tháng
ví dụ tháng 11 sheet tháng Hai 1 sheet 2
mỗi một ít là một lớp học thì tùy vào
cái mục đích của các bạn nhá để các bạn
quản lý thì bạn sẽ tạo nhiều sheet cho
nó tưởng minh hơn thôi đấy tiếp theo
mình sẽ giới thiệu cho các bạn về hàng
và cột các bạn Thúy Nga mặc định cái
hàng và cố định thì các bạn tạo một cái
file mới thì nó sẽ có độ rộng giống nhau
đấy ví dụ như cái cột C này mà họ tên
các bạn muốn độ rộng rộng ra
các bạn nên giữa các cột C của B vậy và
các bạn giữ thật trái gọn kéo nhá Nếu
muốn rộng ra thì bạn kéo sang phải lại
còn nếu muốn coi vào thì qua kéo cháy
đấy Còn nếu như mà các bạn thích đúng
thích thì là gì À cái độ rộng của nó sẽ
là bằng cái độ rộng của cái ôm dài nhất
còn tích đua vào đây là ví dụ cái ông
Nguyễn Văn A này dài nhất thì cái độ
rộng của nó nó sẽ vừa mới cả cái ô
Nguyễn Văn A đấy ví dụ cái tổng điểm Đây
này cái tổng điểm đang bị thiếu các bạn
thích lúc vào giữa cái cô khác là còn y
nhá Có thích nút này đấy thì nó sẽ mở
rộng các cột khác này để vừa cái ô tổng
điểm nữa đây đây ví dụ như cái cột f nhá
hoặc 1G đây này con thấy này cái độ rộng
này nó thừa so với cái tổng điểm Nếu như
các bạn muốn ko vào ấy thì các bạn là gì
Các bạn có thể giữ được trái Các bạn
chọn nhiều cái cột cũng được thì sau đó
bạn dùng các bạn sẽ kích đúp vào một cái
cột bất kỳ trong 3 cái cục này Ví dụ
mình chọn cái giữa cái cột a và cột f
với nhá Đợi thì nó có cái mũi tên mà sẽ
hai bên này các tỉnh đổ vào đây đợi thì
ba cái
How to lại để nó vừa với cả cái cột lớn
nhất ở đây đợi Nếu như cái cột
PowerPoint này có muốn rộng ra một tí
cho dễ nhìn thì bạn kéo ra đâu đấy thì
tùy các bạn nhắc Nếu như các bạn Bôi đen
cả 3 cái cục này các bạn kéo ra một chút
thì cả ba cái cột này nó sẽ kéo ra một
cái Độ rộng là bằng nhau nhá Đấy là cái
cách mà mình sẽ co dãn cái độ rộng cột
Ok để chèn một cuộc Nữa của em và cột f
thời hạn gì nhá thì các bạn sẽ tích vào
cái cột thép này các bạn nháy chuột phải
và các bạn Insert đấy thì tức là mình sẽ
chèn một cột vào giữa cái cột thép và
một em lúc đấy thì cái kẹp lúc đấy nó sẽ
đẩy sang của g đúng không ạ thì tất cả
cái cục nó sẽ bị dịch sang một ở đây và
cái cột thép này mới ở đây mình sẽ tạo
thì ví dụ mình ở đây là điểm tiếng Anh
đi cái nạn thế đúng không đấy thì bạn sẽ
thêm một đây Còn nếu như muốn thêm nhiều
cô Ví dụ muốn thêm 2 cột sau cái cột em
hè thì họ sẽ Bôi đen cái cột f1g đây này
Đấy tức là mình sẽ mua Đen 2 cột và mình
nháy chuột phải Insert thì là gì nó sẽ Y
Dược hai cột đấy Còn nếu như muốn xóa
cột
ý mình muốn xóa cái cột F là một người
nhá các bạn giữ thật trái các bạn Bôi
đen hai cái kẹp vào cuộc giờ này các bạn
nhé Được phải các bạn biết đi đấy Đấy là
cách mình xóa cột Còn nếu như mà để lựa
chọn nhiều cái cột bằng cách nhau lại ví
dụ B này thì còn thích ở cột b sau đó
bạn giữ cần trôi qua thích ở cột f đấy
mà các bạn muốn chọn cái cột hát nữa thì
bạn vẫn giữ cần chôn các bạn thích một
con hát Thì đấy là để mình lựa chọn
nhiều cột và nó cách nhau đúng không
liên tục để ví dụ mình chèn ba cái cột
trước cái cục mình chọn ở đây nha Thì
bạn nháy được phải của bạn sở đấy Thịt
ba cái cột mình chọn rồi đây này Nó sẽ
thêm 3 ở đây một này 23 đấy còn thấy cho
Đấy bây giờ Xóa ba khổ này bằng cách các
bạn tích vào cột này các bạn giữ cần cho
để gọn giữa cần chôn các bạn thích ở cột
b Các bạn nhớ được cả các bạn biết đi Để
như vậy mình đã xóa cái cột mình chọn
rồi nhé Khách hàng cũng vậy khách hàng
thì tương tự như của tôi Các bạn muốn gì
Các bạn muốn mở rộng cái độ rộng hàng
thế cận kéo xuống đây để các bạn mở rộng
ra các bạn kéo lên để bạn thu hẹp và Thế
còn nếu những
Ừ thì nó sẽ mở rộng các cột này để vừa
mới cả cái độ rộng lại đây nhá tương tự
cái việc mà chèn hàng Ví dụ mình muốn
chèn một cái hàng ở giữa cái hành số 3
và số 4 hú ạ thì các bạn sẽ tích vào cái
hành số 4 này còn nhớ được phạt các bạn
Yên Sở đấy thì nó sẽ chèn một cái hàng ở
giữa các cuộc số 3 và số 4 vừa xong chỉ
các hành số 4 Vừa xong nó sẽ đẩy xuống
hàng số 5 này đấy vào một cái hàng mới ở
cái hành số 4 được tạo ra đây lấy ví dụ
ở đây mình viết là Diện Nguyễn Nguyễn
Thị Nguyễn Thị ít đi ra đấy thì mình sẽ
thêm được một cái bạn ở đây vào đây và
các bạn sinh nhập các cái thành phần
tương ứng nhá thì tương tự để xóa hàng
thì bạn rất thích và Khách hàng cần xóa
thôi Còn nếu như bạn muốn xóa nhiều hàng
thì bạn giữ thêm cái cần chôn Ví dụ mình
xóa cả hàng thứ hai đúng không các bạn
sẽ tích vào cái hàng thứ hai này các bạn
nhớ phải và các bạn nên ít đi thì như
vậy là nó xóa hai cái hàng vừa trộn vừa
xong lúc ạ Để khá là hay ok bây giờ mà
để di chuyển hàng nhá Ví dụ mình sẽ tích
vào cái cột số 2 này để
nhà hàng này kỳ diệu các bạn rất tích
vận hành số 2 sau đó gọn Di chuột trái
đến một cái cạnh Bất kỳ khi mà nó có bốn
cái mũi tên ra bốn góc Vậy thì họ giữ
được trái còn kéo đợi nếu như bạn muốn
di chuyển số hàng số 6 thì cao kéo thông
đây đấy thì cái hành số 2 lúc đấy dữ
liệu nó sẽ kéo theo hàng số 6 này Bây
giờ muốn di chuyển lên chị ạ Họ sẽ tích
và một cảnh bất kỳ mà nó có cái mũi tên
này còn di chuyển lên đấy nó sẽ kéo lên
thì tương tự vậy Cái hộp này chẳng hạn
nhé cái cột này mình muốn diện muốn cái
cột ngày sinh này nó xuống dưới cùng
đúng không Thì bạn sẽ kéo như một ngày
sinh hạ xuống dưới cùng có đây đấy thì
lúc này cái cục này nó rỗng để tạo có
thể nhớ được phải của anh Billy đi bây
giờ giả sử mình không phải là di chuyển
mà mình muốn chèn nhá bây giờ mình muốn
chèn cái cột ngày sinh này giữa cái cột
C và cuộc D thì mình làm như thế nào các
bạn tích vào cái cột ngày sinh là của y
để đúng không các bạn cũng di chuyển và
một cái bất kỳ khi mà nó có 40 Mũi tên
này khoảng giữa trái kéo và các bạn dữ
em ship nha khi có bạn giữ phím sẽ bị
thì thay vì là lúc đấy lựa chọn cả cái
cổ thì nó này nó nên lựa chọn các cây
gạt này thôi đúng không ạ Để lúc nào nó
sẽ chọn cái cột mà nằm giữa hai cái cột
mà gọi chọn đây ví dụ mình nằm giữa vào
cột C và cột b đấy nhá thì nó sẽ chèn
vào đây này Đấy còn giữ ship và bạn giữ
được trái bây giờ có phải bỏ được trả
trước sau khi các bạn bỏ thật tráng rồi
thì các bạn với bọn miễn phí ra đấy thì
như vậy là cái cột ngày sinh đó đã được
di chuyển xuống đây đấy
a tiếp theo mình sẽ giới thiệu với các
bạn một nhóm Seo nhé một nhóm xem là gì
Giả sử mình Bôi đen một cái nhóm sao này
đấy các bạn có thể di chuyển một cái
nhóm Xem này đấy cũng giống như các bạn
di chuyển hàng và cổ thôi đấy còn gì
chuyển sang đây hoặc các bạn di chuyển
lại nhé Phải con lại di chuyển về đây
đây là cách để bạn di chuyển của nhóm
xem đây là sử mình tặng một cái tên mới
nhắc ví dụ là Nguyễn Văn B đi đấy ngày
sinh đã chọn có thể nhập bất kỳ ví dụ
ngày mùng 1 tháng 1 năm lẻ hay 2019 Hạnh
Thế nhá thấy điện toán 7 là sáu là 8 đây
là 9 đi đây ví dụ cái cổng điểm vì xóa
đây nhá các bạn sẽ nháy được phải là cục
gì gọi live đi thì cái hàm thì mình sẽ
nói là cái video sau nhé đấy tên điển
tiếng Anh ở đây ví dụ lớp 7 đi Đấy bây
giờ mình muốn kéo cái bạn Nguyễn Văn A
này sao bạn nữa b thì mình làm như thế
nào thì bạn sẽ Donal với bạn Nguyễn Văn
A này họ sẽ thích của một cách bất kỳ
khi vào nó
số tiền ra bốn góc thì bạn giữ được trái
cận kéo này sau đó bạn giữ thêm phím
ship lại bạn sẽ tích vào giữa cái đây
này đây khi mà nó ở dưới cột b này và nó
chỉ lựa chọn ở giữa hàng bốn hàng năm
thì các Bỏ từ trái ra về sau đó Toàn bỏ
tím ship nữa đấy thì như vậy toàn bộ
thông tin của bạn Nguyễn Văn A này sẽ
được dịch xuống đây để cậu thấy cũng rất
là hay ở đây giả sử mình nhập nhầm cái
điểm của hai bạn này nhá bây giờ ví dụ
bạn Nguyễn Văn B điểm lại ở dưới này cơ
bạn Nguyễn Văn An địa điểm ở trên này cơ
thì mình là như thế nào giả sử bây giờ
mình sẽ Model cái điểm của bạn Nguyễn
Văn A này để đoạn giữa trái và các bạn
Duy nhá thì gọi sẽ lựa chọn được bốn cái
điểm ở đây sau đó còn giữ ship này và
còn kéo cái này lên thì bạn sẽ kéo lên ở
giữa cái hành số 2 và số 3 đấy tuần bỏ
chữa cháy ra và các bạn bỏ phím ship ra
rỡ như vậy mình đã hoán đổi điểm của hai
bạn này với nhau rồi đúng không ạ Đấy
khá là hay đấy là cái cách mà mình di
chuyển nhé ví dụ mình lựa chọn
ở vùng dữ liệu này nhá các bạn giữ được
trái và các bạn kéo này thì mặc định ở
cái nên bóp vào đây nó sẽ lựa chọn cái ô
đầu tiên là cái oc2 này nhá Nhưng mà ở
đây mình muốn đặt tên cho toàn bộ vùng
dữ liệu ở đây ví dụ mình đặt tên ở đây
là dịp ví dụ là phòng tài chính là hạn
Thế nhá Để gọi m Bây giờ con thoát ra
con sẽ tích chuột vào một ô bất kỳ sau
đó các bạn lên cái phần lên mốc này cái
phần tam giác nhỏ đấy còn tích vào đây
khi còn tích vào cái phòng tài chính thì
mặc định nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ các dữ
liệu của phòng tài chính mà mình đặt tên
Lúc nãy bạn đặt các bạn tích vào đâu bất
kỷ thì khi ngọn lên đây có thích vào đây
Các bạn chọn phòng tài chính thì nó sẽ
lựa chọn vùng dữ liệu của phòng tài
chính mà mình đặt tên nước trước nhé đấy
là cái phần mình đặt tên Ok sau khi các
bạn đã thao tác với các sheet cách hành
các cột rồi nhá Hoặc là các cái phạm vi
rồi nhá bây giờ mình muốn lưu các file
này cái lưu file nghĩa là gì thì lúc khi
mà các bạn đặt tên file thì nó chưa có
dữ liệu gì đúng không sau này các bạn
cập nhật thêm để các bạn cập nhật thêm
các thông tin của phòng Tài
mọi người các bạn tạo một cái sĩ là
phòng kế hoạch bây giờ các bạn lưu file
này để nó sẽ cập nhật cái trạng thái mà
mình đã làm vừa sau muốn học cậu sẽ vào
đấy đẹp pha các bạn sẽ bấm Xếp đấy thì
như vậy là cái file file bài số 1 làm
quen với excel đã được cập nhật các
thông tin này rồi nhá bây giờ để đóng
file thì gọi sẽ tích vào cái dấu X ở
trên này để còn đóng pha nhá Khi có bạn
trở vào Cái lỗi này nó sẽ có cái chữ Cờ
Lau để gọi đóng pha đấy Bây giờ còn đóng
đi đấy Thì lúc nãy mình yêu phải ở đâu
mình như file ở cái folder Excel cơ bản
đến nâng cao và desktop hay là còn tích
luôn vào đây phải gọi sẽ mở rộng cái cửa
sổ Windows này ra mình lưu ở cái bài số
1 đúng ạ đấy thì cái file mà lúc nãy
mình như là cái xe này bài số 1 làm quen
với cha của anh thấy chưa Đấy bây giờ để
mở file nhé thì gọi sẽ thích đút vào đây
để gọi mở file đấy đấy là cái cách mở
file thì ngoài cái cách này thì có bạn
có thể mở bằng cách cách dẹp Ví dụ mình
đóng lại nhá Bây giờ mình lại khởi động
lại Excel đây các bạn vào
khi chọn gọi Excel có enter thì bạn thấy
không cái file mà mình tạo gần nhất này
nó sẽ lên ở cái mục ở đây là bài số 1
làm quen với excel đấy thì các bạn có
thể mở bằng cách giờ có thích luôn Vào
cái file này hoặc các bạn có thể tích và
cái Open rồi nhá Nếu như bạn không thấy
ở cái mục di dân ở đây tức là các cái
file gần nhất thì các có thể và với phần
Open đấy và các bạn brown brown đến cái
thư mục mà mình lưu cái file đấy đúng
không Ví dụ lúc đấy mình như desktop và
Excel cơ bản đến nâng cao đó bài số 1 và
gọi chọn vào đây Các bạn bấm Open để thì
như vậy Mình có ba cái cách để mở file
đúng không khi các bạn mở file này lên
thế bạn có thể tích ở đây để các bạn thu
nhỏ cửa sổ Excel này lại đợi Còn nếu như
các bạn muốn minimart tức là địa các bạn
sẽ thu nhỏ cái file Excel này xuống với
thanh phát ra các bạn sẽ thu nhỏ Đây để
con bỏ các ứng dụng khác nhé đấy là cái
cách mà mình thu nhỏ Còn nếu như quá
thích vào đây thì nó lại Mở cái file này
Ừ để họ sẽ tích là cái vua này này thì
nó sẽ mở rộng cái váy xe lại toàn màn
hình ok Giả sử cái file Đây là cái file
dữ liệu của 5 20 20 nhá bây giờ mình
muốn tạo 1 cái file giống như thế này
cho năm 2021 để mình cập nhật Cái dữ
liệu mới á đấy thì gọi cho vào cái file
này các bạn chọn cfs đấy và các bạn sẽ
chọn cái nơi mà bạn muốn chứa cái khay
này đúng ạ để bạn sẽ thích bảo mật ong
giả sử mình vẫn chứ ở cái folder này nhá
và mình sẽ tạo đây là ví dụ ở đây là năm
2021 hạ thế nhá Đấy tức là rượu mình sẽ
tạo một cái file copy của cái file này
Đấy thì mình sẽ chọn xét nhá và lúc này
mình sẽ cập nhật mới dữ liệu của năm
2021 Thì đấy là cái cfs nhé trước là
mình sẽ tạo một cái file mới từ cái file
mà mình đã có bằng cách mình sẽ FS giống
như kiểu ví dụ các bạn làm một cái file
mà các bạn có nhiều phiên bản đúng không
ạ ví dụ là phiên bản thứ nhất là các bạn
chưa chắc chắn thì bạn có thể lưu sau
một cái phiên bản thứ hai phiên bản thứ
ba thì các bạn
khi phải xếp em này nhá Ok Bây giờ mình
sẽ đóng cái file này lại các bạn chú nhé
để đóng file thì bạn sẽ bấm thì các bạn
sẽ bấm ăn F4 để Bọn nó khoa lại các bạn
sẽ giữ phim an và các bạn F4 này các bạn
trong cái file này ạ Đấy vậy thì như vậy
bạn thấy ở đây có 2 file rồi không ạ một
cái file là làm quen với excel và một
cái file là diện làm quen với excel và
thêm cái chữ được năm 2021 đây là lúc
đấy mình sẽ ghép thì nó sẽ tạo ra một
cái file mới thôi bây giờ để xóa phái
xem nhé chẳng hạn xóa file này nó còn sẽ
nháy được phải này điện thoại sẽ bấm
Delete ở đây đấy hoặc là Rịa các bạn chỉ
cần kích vào đây Các bạn bấm phím delete
trên bàn phím này đợi thì nó sẽ tự xóa
nhá thì lớn như chọn xóa như thế thì nó
sẽ vào cái thùng rác đây này Đây cái
thùng rác của mình chính là cái file vừa
xong mày xóa đúng không Bây giờ nếu như
mình vẫn lưu lại nha các bạn xinh nháy
chuột phải vào cái file này các bạn chọn
restore đấy thì như vậy cái file này nó
đã diện nó đã trở về cái thư mục chiếc
nó rồi đúng không Toàn tích ở đây để cậu
thấy cái file này nó trở về
Ừ cái cách xóa thứ hai là các bạn nhá
đều phải là các bạn biết đấy nó sẽ tự
xóa nhé Cuối cùng là cái phần câu hỏi
nhá các bạn Thúy mình sẽ để cái câu hỏi
cũng như là cái folder của bài 01 ngày
này trong phần mô tả phía dưới video thì
các bạn sẽ tải về con mở câu hỏi lên nhá
Còn nếu như các bạn nào mà không biết
cách tải về thì các bạn xem lại cái bài
đầu tiên cái bài mở đầu mình đã hướng
dẫn chi tiết cách tải về rồi B có bản
tính lui vào đây Đấy cái file câu hỏi
này qua thích lên thì câu hỏi cho các
bạn là dịp mình sẽ đã có hai cái câu hỏi
là 2 cái thao tác lưu file tư là cái xếp
và cách xếp s thì nó giống và khác nhau
như thế nào Câu hỏi số 2 khi nhập ngày
tháng năm trong Excel Vậy mình có thể
đổi cái mặc định là ngậm ngày trước rồi
đến tháng đến 50 tức là rẻ thông thường
với mặc định của Excel nào mình sẽ nhập
tháng trước sau đến ngày đến năm Bây giờ
mình có thể đổi mình có muốn nhập là
ngày trước sau đến tháng và đến năm
giống như là kiểu mà người Việt Nam hay
làm thì mình có làm
anh đấy Đấy là hai cái câu hỏi nhá các
bạn hãy trả lời 2 câu hỏi này trong cái
phần comment ở phía dưới video nhé Ok
như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học ngày
hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi
các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật
video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia sẻ
để giúp mọi người cộng Excel nhé Xin
chào và